[Musique]
la chaise elle tombe au pire du bêtisier
Jonathan j'imagine que comme Serge Le
mytho ou vous parlez évidemment
couramment italien Mike
moulto very
vous êtes arrivés on vous a dit que vous
étiez et lettres
c'est la première chose
vous l'avez bien pris bien évidemment
c'est votre première mostra si je ne
m'abuse est-ce que on se la pète pas un
peu après en se disant ah ouais je viens
de faire ma première Bosta non alors
attends pour l'instant je suis pas dans
la phase
répéter je suis plus dans la phase wow
émotion tu as l'impression de faire
partie d'une histoire quand même du
cinéma donc les tu en prends plein les
yeux tu es un peu dans l'émotion on va
dire
Eric teledano oui dites-vous que vous
avez je le cite vous avez quelque chose
des héros italien parce qu'avec vous
tout devient plus léger y compris les
les choses les plus graves
est-ce que vous vous retrouvez dans dans
cette filiation italienne oui parce que
moi j'aime beaucoup déjà le cinéma
italien le néo-réalisme italien tout ça
c'est des films que j'ai vu
tu vois éviter le nid le pigeon il y a
des films comme ça qui m'ont marqué des
acteurs et il y a effectivement dans la
grande misère chez eux toujours ce cette
joie cette cette légèreté que j'arrive à
mettre alors que les gars sont tous au
bout de leur vie qui a quasiment pas de
futures et
effectivement cette
en tout cas j'aime et j'ai peut-être en
commun cette chose avec ce cinéma là en
tout cas que
voilà c'est ça mettre de la légèreté tu
vois les les enterrements il y a les
fous rires et j'aime quand il y a ces
deux pandas moi dans les films bon on va
parler un peu de Venise vous êtes venus
ici présenter mais qui off ouais un film
de Cédric Kahn ta fille qui comme son
titre lundi se passe dans les coulisses
d'un tournage sur fond de conflit social
conflit social qui se répercute aussi
sur le sur l'histoire du film et vous y
incarnez Alain Alain qui est un comédien
égocentrique et infernal c'est un pure
rôle de composition je ne la compo
mais en vrai c'est assez jouissif de
jouer un acteur
insupportable
égocentrique qui est véritablement prêt
à tout pour choper enfin pour être au
centre des choses des scènes ils veulent
les répliques des uns des autres c'est
c'est très jouissif à jouer après
comment dire ça peut exister moi j'en ai
rarement vu des gens comme ça
en vrai c'est une rencontre moins que
que qu'on peut l'imaginer tu vois c'est
très très rare
poupée c'est n'importe quoi là c'est
quoi pourquoi tu coupes c'était super
parce que tout le monde improvise là
tu veux que je te cadre tout le temps tu
veux être tout seul dans le plan c'est
ça que tu veux c'est ce n'est pas un
truc d'ego là que je suis en train de te
faire bien sûr ça n'a rien à voir je
suis à 100 % dans ton film je le vis de
l'Intérieur depuis le début ton film
est-ce que c'est vrai que Cédric Cannes
a pensé à vous en vous découvrons dans
Serge Le mytho ouais ouais alors
peut-être pas pour ce film en tout cas
je sais que il avait aimé Serge Le mytho
il adorait Serge Vito je pense qu'il va
partir de là c'est très bien un jour
qu'on travaille ensemble alors je
parlais des deux films que vous venez
présenter à Venise et donc le Cédric
Cannes et il y a aussi
avec 5A c'est c'est le nouveau Quentin
du pieux comment est-ce que vous avez
intégré le metaves du pieu
Quentin Dupieux et en fait à la base je
vais pas jouer sur là de Dali il y a eu
un désistement
et moi je devais jouer le producteur et
et il y a eu un désistement sur un des
Dali et
il m'a dit ça me dirait de le faire j'ai
j'ai sauté sur le casse j'ai eu avec
grand plaisir et le cinéma de Quentin du
feu comme tu dis cette Multiverse c'est
totalement un quelque chose fait maison
il a le film dans la tête il est il est
enthousiaste H24 Dali était espagnol
c'est pas une révélation fracassante que
tu regardes
et de la même manière que Serge Le mytho
est arrivé ici à Venise en parlant
couramment italien est-ce qu'il va en
repartir en parlant couramment espagnol
mais c'est possible que
tout simplement bonsoir en fait vous
êtes l'homme de tous les possibles de
toutes les langues